one of the men who just won one of these
important races congressman Ron de
santis is now the Republican nominee for
Florida governor he's here now in his
first interview since his primary
victory congressman De Santis
congratulations you must be feeling
pretty good tonight
yeah now Laura I remember you and I
talking after we did that debate on Fox
News and you were like you're not going
to be behind much longer after this and
sure enough I mean we really pulled the
head we had the president come at the
end of July with a huge event for us and
we really just had unstoppable momentum
and the good thing is we're gonna carry
this all the way through November and
post a strong victory so we can continue
on Florida's path to success and make it
even better are you surprised that
Gilliam wins on the Democrat side so
he'll be your challenger endorsed by
Bernie Sanders as you just heard us talk
about Soros and Tom Steyer both pitched
in total about $650,000 it seemed to
make a difference down the homestretch
so you're gonna be you're gonna be
running against a hard left
former Tallahassee or Tallahassee mayor
he is the most liberal candidate that
the Democratic Party has ever nominated
in the state of Florida by a country
mile in a governor's race he wants to
abolish ice he wants a billion dollar
tax increase he wants a single-payer
health care system in Florida which
would bankrupt the state I'm trying to
make Florida even better he wants to
make Florida a Venezuela but he also
combines a far-left ideology with
managerial incompetence as mayor of
Tallahassee his tenure has been
absolutely disastrous Tallahassee is one
of if not the most crime-ridden city in
all of Florida year after year rising
crime he's embroiled in a lot of
corruption scandals this is not a this
guy can't even run the city of
Tallahassee
there's no way Florida voters can
entrust him with our entire state now
congressman De Santis
in your in your jubilation and your in
your celebration you may have missed
that
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes tweeted out
congratulations not to you but to your
challenger Andrew
saying the progressive movement is
transforming the country and he proved
that again tonight Gilliam ran on
Medicare for all legalizing marijuana
abolish ice and more Thank You Florida
voters on 2 November I'd wear that as a
badge of honor tonight congressman well
look we have people who in Florida who
have fled socialist countries like Cuba
and Venezuela they don't want that
imported into Florida we also have
people who flee from left-wing policies
and states like New York and Connecticut
and they don't want that imported into
Florida so I think we want to keep
Florida great we want to keep it going
in a good direction and going in the
direction of a Nicasio Cortes is just
untenable and it will not happen in
Florida congressman some of your critics
will throw out this they'll say well you
won on Trump's coattails but you're
short on your own policy initiatives on
a statewide level how do you answer your
critics yeah well it's not true at all I
mean we have a solid vision for how to
create high high-paying jobs in Florida
I've been very strong on our
environmental problems and solving our
water crisis that we have in different
parts of the state and then only one of
the few people who's ever stood up
against some of the entrenched interests
Laura you know they were spending
millions of dollars to stop me in the
race and yet we did that we've been very
strong on illegal immigration saying we
need e-verify in Florida we can't have
sanctuary cities I've been somebody
that's been a wholesale supporter of
education reform from parental choice to
vocational education in the classrooms
to more civics education so we've been
talking about these key issues time and
time again and we're gonna continue to
do that and spread the message far and
wide
did you hear from Putnam tonight did he
give you a call yeah no look he's a
class guy he worked very hard he looked
he was a tough competitor I mean people
say oh you won big but I mean this guy
built a huge organization he raised a
boatload of money and he ran a very
tough race I mean tried to knock me
around a lot that's politics but but
he's supportive of where we're going he
knows we got to keep Florida and
Republican hands and he's gonna help me
so that's how these things go I would
have supported him if he had beaten me
and you got to move forward as a team
absolutely and the president is he
very popular in Florida the endorsement
did help a lot but he also did a great
job on the hustings congressman
congratulations thanks so much